laura usa una mezcla de granos con
tostados oscuro y ligero para hacer café
en su cafetería ella necesita en total
80 kilogramos de granos de café para su
siguiente orden los granos con tostado
oscuro cuestan 3 pesos por kilogramo los
granos con tostado ligero cuestan 2
pesos por kilogramo y ella quiere gastar
220 en total aquí tenemos las gráficas
que muestran el sistema de ecuaciones
para este escenario donde x es el número
de kilogramos de granos de tostado
oscuro y que es el número de kilogramos
de grano de tostado ligero que ella
déjame bajar un poco en la pantalla para
que puedas observarlas observa esta
recta en azul y escribir en azul está x
lo que representa es el número de
kilogramos de grano tostado oscuro
y que es esta de aquí es el número de
kilogramos de grano tostado ligero y
ella quiere comprar en total 80
kilogramos eso es lo que nos dicen acá
arriba lo subrayar en azul ella necesita
en total 80 kilogramos de granos de café
para su siguiente orden esta restricción
de que la suma de los kilogramos de
grano de tostado oscuro y ligero deben
de ser 80 está representado por esta
ecuación que tenemos acá abajo y si
queremos graficar entonces nos dará esta
recta en color azul ok y la otra
restricción 3x bueno esto representa el
precio del grano tostado oscuro que es
de 3 pesos por kilogramo
por lo tanto 3x es cuánto gasta ella en
el tostado oscuro mientras que 2 g es
cuánto gasta ella en el tostado ligero
porque cuesta dos pesos por kilogramo y
220 es lo que quiere gastar y eso mismo
es lo que nos dicen acá arriba observa
los granos con tostado oscuro cuestan
tres pesos por kilogramo los granos con
tostado ligero cuestan dos pesos por
kilogramo y ella quiere gastar 220 pesos
en total así que esta ecuación en verde
lo que nos dice es de una forma
matemática lo que acabo de subrayar en
verde y la recta en verde nos muestra
todas las combinaciones xy que coinciden
con esta restricción bien ahora hagamos
algo interesante no se etiquetaron
cuatro puntos se de
e íbamos a pensar que representa cada
uno de estos puntos
por ejemplo este punto ce este punto ce
que está en la recta verde pero está por
arriba de la recta azul
que nos dice que representa este punto
ce pausa el vídeo y piénsalo
bueno estar sobre la recta verde
significa decir que la cantidad que ya
compra de tostado oscuro más la cantidad
que ella compra de tostado ligero es
exactamente igual a 220 pesos así que en
definitiva aquí está gastando 220 pesos
aquí en el punto ce pero cuántos
kilogramos está usando bueno para esta
equis dada observa que estemos por
arriba de la recta azul significa que
nos estamos ocupando exactamente 80
kilogramos y lo podemos ver justo aquí
ella está usando 10 kilogramos de
tostado oscuro y parece que
aproximadamente 95 kilogramos de tostado
ligero y si sumamos estos dos valores en
definitiva estamos arriba de 80
kilogramos parece que ya está usando
aproximadamente 105 kilogramos
así que el punto ce es el escenario
donde ella gasta exactamente 220 pesos
pero ella está usando más de 80
kilogramos porque ella no está
cumpliendo esta segunda restricción que
tenemos en color azul estamos por encima
de esta recta
ok y ahora pensemos en el punto de que
representa el punto de pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrar lo bueno estar sobre
la recta azul significa que cumplimos
esta restricción que dice que la suma de
los kilogramos de tostado oscuro y
ligero es igual a 80 kilogramos por lo
tanto ella usa exactamente 80 kilogramos
justo aquí pero qué hay de su gasto en
este punto que está por debajo de la
recta verde nos dice que estamos
gastando menos que 220 pesos incluso
podemos intentarlo observar si tenemos 3
veces 20 ok más dos veces 60 eso es lo
mismo que 60 más 120 lo cual es menor
que 220 observa que este es el punto
donde cumplimos esta restricción en azul
no estamos cumpliendo la restricción
verde estamos gastando menos justo aquí
y ahora que hay del punto f
bueno el punto efe está por debajo de
ambas rectas así que pausa el vídeo y
piensa un poco qué significa
bueno estar por debajo de ambas rectas
significa que si se gastan 220 pesos y
se usan 80 kilogramos y puedes verlo
fácilmente si ves los números por aquí
no tienes que hacerlo pero esto nos
ayudará a sentirnos bien parece que
aproximadamente ella está usando 30
kilogramos de tostado oscuro y 30
kilogramos de tostado ligero entonces
aquí tenemos la situación en donde ella
está usando 60 kilogramos en total ok y
eso es menor que 80 kilogramos por lo
tanto no estamos sobre la recta en azul
y si observamos cuánto gasta bueno
tenemos 3 por 30 más dos veces 30 lo
cual es 90 + 60 y eso en definitiva es
menor que 220 por eso es que este punto
también está por debajo de la
en verde está por debajo de ambas rectas
bien por último pero no por eso menos
importante que representa el punto
bueno observa el punto está en ambas
rectas
eso significa que cumple ambas
restricciones aquí tenemos el escenario
donde ella gasta exactamente 220 pesos y
el número total de kilogramos entre
tostado oscuro y ligero que ella está
usando es de 80 kilogramos y si quieres
decir oye cuál es la combinación de
tostado oscuro y ligero que necesita
para que se cumplan ambas restricciones
bueno eso es lo que representa
la intersección de ambas rectas